Before explaining how projection works, let's talk about how the perspective
camera is set in 3Js. It's similar to the Orthographic Camera, in fact, the
creation call has few parameters. We know what the last three are. The aspect
ratio is the image width divided by height, followed by the near and far
planes. Remember the view frustum? It's back at last. The near and far
distances are measured from the tip of the pyramid, where the camera is placed,
down a central axis. Back when I was a young man, we called near and far by the
names hither and yon, which I think is more poetic. You'll still occasionally
see the terms hither and yon used in products, so keep an eye out. The first
argument for the perspective camera is the field of view. This is the angle
between the top and bottom planes of the view pyramid. Notice that in 3JS, this
number is specified in degrees, unlike many other angles, which use radians.
The field of view along with the aspect ratio fully described the locations of
the four sides of the pyramid. For the orthographic camera, we define the
location of every side of our volume box. Here the view is assumed to be
symmetric around the central axis. In other words, instead of, a top an a
bottom value, we need just a single angle describing both, the field of view.
Same thing with the right an left, the aspect ratio along with the angle is
enough. This is 3.js's way of doing things, an 99.9% of the time it's what you
want. That said, it's entirely possible to specify each side of the pyramid.
And webgl itself has a frustum that does just this. If you later change values
on the camera itself, such as the field of view near or far planes, in 3js you
need to call camera, update projection matrix in order to have these changes
take effect. For most demos these camera parameters are usually set once on
creation and rarely touched, so 3js doesn't spend any time checking them each
frame. If you change these values while running your program, calling update
projection matrix has three js evaluate these parameters and form a new
projection matrix.